hey reject nation good to be back hope
you guys had a good Easter hope you guys
pulled some good pranks on people for
April Fool's Day I did not really do
much of either of those things there was
bat metal and then bat metal returned
and in the style of the 90s
it is now bat metal forever oh boy I
just showed John the first to bat metal
so he's never seen them yeah you really
like them I think I laughed a lot that
metal forever now
shredders recycling april o'neil yeah
[Music]
I stress I grade this is to follow up
after ready player one yeah yeah I think
it up Metalocalypse
[Music]
yes the time has come
whoa
[Music]
[Laughter]
watch
[Music]
Hoddy
I was snapped negative robbers all
healed up
[Music]
yeah or for Jimmy
she's back to being clothed nice 40
ah
[Music]
he's back the whole time
eyes our eyes
[Music]
it's too heavy
credits hey they don't have credits Oh
Brendon small does work on these okay Oh
power glove Oh Cal this makes so much
sense there's a really cool credits
[Music]
Hey Bruce you know I just think about it
and maybe we try something with his DNA
I mean it's all over the place now I got
better idea the only question is
oh that oh cool it's it's just like the
amazing spider-man 2 like 16 but was
just so many Joker's got all these
patrons yeah yeah well I mean if they're
if this is Brett and smallest thing or
if it's you know Metalocalypse related
I'm not surprised yeah what do you know
I don't know what you know Metalocalypse
was the show on Adult Swim that was a
similar kind of animated show about a
heavy-metal band and it's kind of absurd
and off the walls ah
so like partway through the first couple
I was thinking like those guys like a
crazier more you know comic book and
more reference oriented version
Metalocalypse I mean it says he at least
dude the main song and the credit than
the lives I said in the middle of the
reaction part of it I think bat metal
could not have returned at a better time
since after ready player one yeah so
much jam-packed with references
throughout and then what I like about
the bat metal series is that it's like
yeah you get a lot of DC references a
lot of Batman references the bat family
but they're always throwing in a bunch
of other ones just like huge franchises
of today or throwbacks of stuff you got
the mummy in there at one point they
might have been diesel in there oh boy
yeah even get Rick and Morty in there
yeah aerials back aerials back man
they're really sexual has a hell and a
back girl here hopefully the DC EU does
the same exact thing I'm sure that's
what everyone is hoping for oh you just
get a naughty sexy back girl no real
character just hot well you know if they
start embracing the heavy metal
aesthetic in the live-action movies you
you might just get your hit and
especially the way they work in these
references because it's clear it's like
any type of situation that relates to
another property where that same thing
happened or whatever you know especially
they're trying to resurrect the Joker's
they're looking at different you know
like resurrection you know a pretty neat
little way to tie in all these different
gags and stuff this is Nate man and I
like that we actually got to hear them
talk for at one point I'm hoping that
for the next one you know next two years
I'm hoping that we're able to get a
a little bit more scene work yeah I hope
this evolves yeah into like slightly
more of a scene or a sketch each time
with the song around it and the songs
just keep on getting crazier and crazier
and you know more polished and intricate
I think that would the way there's been
like Teen Titans go the Lego Batman
movie the Batman movies and the DC EU I
wouldn't be surprised if bat metal
himself got his own movie franchise one
day that would be banana sandwich right
there are rated animated Batman comedy
right oh dude that would be fun or some
kind of like series of some sort that's
you know beyond the YouTube yeah there
maybe something that plays late-night I
mean he's already cracked Adult Swim but
in something like that where you can get
crazy and take advantage of the
animation stuff I loved it this was well
worth the wait thank you already
business alright guys well thanks for
telling us that was out you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell and we'll catch you on
the flippety-flip udders